the family of a hit and run victim still
looking for answers three weeks after
the deadly crash it happened in October
on the Durango exit of the 215 Ryan
mathie joins us live from the Nevada
State Police Headquarters with more Ryan
yeah Kirsten his name was Tony Tomas
three weeks ago Nevada State Police
brought forward seemingly the only video
evidence of the car in question but that
has not been enough to find it and it's
left the Tomas family both clueless and
grieving
we can't heal with without without
Justice we cannot more than three weeks
left in the dark the Tomas family
grieving the loss of 27 year old Tony
Tomas who knows they'll run wherever you
know and possibly not care to do it
again but the case has yet to be solved
the crash occurred in an area out of
view of security cameras and at night
police confirm a car and Tomas collided
before the car's driver sped off the
only evidence released so far this gas
station footage of a van with scratches
to its right side and now this photo of
the same van parked near Elkhorn and
Montecito pretty much just saying that
it's a Ford ecoline is not going to do
it but his sister and mother saying
Communications from investigators have
been near To None Nevada State Police
tell 8 news now it's identified over a
hundred Vans matching the description
but none that positively hit Tomas
for now Family remembers the Hawaiian
native like this with the Aloha Spirit
doing what he loved I gotta bury my own
you know my own nephew in two days
family from the islands now flying in
for his memorial service on Saturday
with the hopes the missing piece of this
puzzle will soon be found are you
expecting answers
I'm expecting answers I'm not giving up
hope this is it at the end you know
we're going to find you
now if anything the family hopes this
will bring more awareness to being alert
while behind the wheel now NSP they also
add if you see this vehicle or at least
think you do the number one thing to get
the license plate number and then to
call them you can call them or be
anonymous at Crime Stoppers both of
those numbers on our website right now
reporting live outside NSP headquarters
Ryan Matthey 8 News Now
that Memorial and celebration of life is
this Saturday at the Serenity Funeral
Home on Almond Tree Lane his family
opening the service to anyone who would
like to pay their respects